-Our next guest is a Tony-nominated
and Grammy Award-winning actor you know from "Mindhunter,"
"The Matrix Resurrections," and his work on Broadway
in "Hamilton" and "Spring Awakening."
He stars in the new film "Knock at the Cabin,"
which is in theaters this Friday.
Let's take a look.
-I don't know what's going on here,
but where are the keys to the truck you guys came in?
I'm taking my family, and we're leaving.
♪♪
-Do you really think that everything that happened today,
everything we've seen...
do you really think it's all just a coincidence?
-Yes.
I think it's all a coincidence.
Some horrible, unexplainable coincidence.
Or it has to be a trick! I have to believe that!
-You already don't believe that.
-Please welcome back to the show Jonathan Groff, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
How are you?
-I'm so good. How are you?
-It's been too long since you've been here.
-I know. I have to tell you that --
You don't know this,
but we spent a lot of COVID together, you and I.
-Oh, yeah? -Yeah.
You were like my special friend.
I couldn't really watch the news in those first several months.
-Yeah, it was a tough time. -I would have a drink
and a protein bar, and I would go to my bed,
and I would sit and I would watch you.
And I can't thank you enough for getting me through that time.
You're just, like, the best. [ Cheers and applause ]
-That's so nice of you to say. -You're just the best.
-It was very special knowing that people were protein-barring
and drinking their way through it with me.
And then I will say I introduced "Frozen" to my kids,
and that was a very tricky time to have kids.
And so I -- I had great love for you
that then obviously hit a point, and then it just --
-Turned into resentment. -Yeah.
Obviously, it's nice to see you and put a face to you again.
But your voice -- No.
-"What are you talking about, Seth?"
-This is so cool to see you in an M. Night movie
because obviously you've done darker stuff,
right, like "Mindhunter," but this is like full horror.
Never done it before.
-Full, tearful horror, yeah. -Was it --
I mean, he must be such an exciting person to work with.
-Yeah, I was so excited to get
to even audition for him and meet him online.
And working with him was amazing.
He's incredibly specific.
It was incredibly intense in that cabin.
But we -- we really had so much fun and kind of formed
a little family with our cast. It was great.
-That's a really cool thing to go through.
Do you have -- I mean, I feel like I know mine.
Do you remember your first, like, M. Night moment
where you're like, "Oh, my God"? Like, a film of his?
-"I see dead people." -Yeah.
-I mean, that was the one. It's a classic.
-Yeah. -Yeah, "The Sixth Sense."
-It's really amazing that all these years later,
he's still a person that you want to go see his film
because you remember that first twist being so good.
-Yeah.
He's one of those few directors where their name alone
brings people into the theater. It's pretty cool.
-Did you -- Were you a fan of horror growing up?
[ Laughter ]
Maybe. Maybe not.
-Yeah. I feel like --
I was a little bit of an outsider in middle school.
-Yeah. -I feel like the genre
of horror tends to grav-- As an outsider,
I feel, like, gravitated for me.
It was "Scream." -Yeah.
-Yeah. I had the mask. I had the voice changer.
-And you brought it to school?
[ Light laughter ]
Okay, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I would call people and be like, "Surprise, Sidney."
[ Laughter ] -Yeah.
You're begging for outsider once you start doing that.
Now, how old are your nieces now?
-Oh, my gosh. They are...
about to be eight and six.
-Okay. So this is not -- This --
"Knock at the Cabin" is not for them.
-This is not for them. My parents are seeing it --
Or they just have seen it, I guess, tonight.
-Oh, exciting. -Which is really exciting.
My nieces will not be seeing it,
although we did have a really adorable 8-year-old.
She's the exact same age as my niece.
-Who's in the film. -Yes.
-Ben Aldridge and I play husbands,
and Kristen is our daughter.
And we loved her so much.
She is an extraordinary, extraordinary young girl,
and she kills it in the movie.
And we took her to see "Wicked."
[ Audience awws ] -Now, this is pretty exciting.
This was her first Broadway show, correct?
-This was her -- -Okay.
-This was her third Broadway show.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-She'd seen "Aladdin" and "Hamilton."
-She did not see "Hamilton."
Obviously she was a bit too young to see --
-She was born the year I was in "Hamilton."
[ Laughter ] Yeah, she was --
-That speaks to what a hit "Hamilton" is.
-That's so true. -That you can be in it
and she can be that old. -Yeah.
I mean -- And "Wicked" was 20 years old.
-And so what did she -- -And still hitting, by the way.
"Wicked." -Still hitting?
-It's still hitting.
-And, now, how long had it been since you'd seen "Wicked"?
Because I imagine there had been some air there for you, right?
-You know, I realized when we brought her
that actually I brought her to "Wicked"
so that I could see "Wicked" again.
-Yeah. [ Laughter ]
-That was like the tenth time I'd seen "Wicked."
-That's great. And it's still banging.
-It's still banging, and I remember
waiting at the stage door for Idina's autograph.
-Wow! As a -- -I was in high school.
-That's really exciting.
-It was very exciting. -Did you get it?
Did you officially -- Did you succeed?
-I didn't get it. -Wow.
Have you brought this up with her in person since?
-I think I did.
-Yeah. -Yeah.
-Well, hopefully she's learned from it.
It you walk by anybody with a playbill,
just know one day they might make it.
Now, what was her -- Tell me her name again.
I'm sorry. -Kristen.
-And Kristen -- what was her take on "Wicked"?
-She had some notes.
[ Laughter ]
-Very precocious. -Very precocious.
She was like, "Musicals are weird."
-Well. -I was like, "They are."
She was like, "I think I prefer movies to musicals."
But then I kept seeing her kind of catching herself laughing.
-Yeah. -She's at that kind of
precocious 8-year-old age where she's a little resistant,
but then I could see her getting transported by the show.
It's incredible.
-You mentioned your parents are seeing it tonight.
Do you have any expec-- Do they like this genre,
or is this a little out of their -- Okay.
So are you -- I mean, are you a little worried about, like,
scaring the bejesus out of your parents?
-My parents have seen my, like, naked butt on Broadway.
-Yeah.
-You know, in "Spring Awakening."
So watching me cry and talk about the apocalypse --
[ Laughter ]
I think they'll be okay comparatively.
-Right.
Everything's uphill from "Spring Awakening."
-Yes, or, like, with talking to serial killers in "Mindhunter."
This is like, you know --
I think they'll be able to suspend their disbelief.
My mom really had to convince my dad to go.
-Okay. Gotcha. -He's not really a movie guy,
so I can't wait to hear his review.
[ Laughter ]
He's like -- grew up on a dairy farm as a Mennonite,
so I'm going to be interested to see
what he thinks of Night's movie.
-And does he shoot straight with his feedback?
-Yeah. -Okay.
-Yeah. He would prefer to be watching football, but...
-Well, there's no game tonight, so --
-No. I didn't even know that. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, this is really exciting. It's coming to Broadway.
You just did it here off Broadway.
"Merrily We Roll Along."
-Yes. -Very famous Sondheim --
[ Cheers and applause ] There we go.
That's the kind of crowd we bring.
-This is -- I got to say.
"Merrily We Roll Along" is a famous flop from 1981.
-Famous flop? -Yeah, they only ran for
16 real performances on Broadway.
And so the fact that, like, there's energy about
"Merrily We Roll Along" is so satisfying,
even that you applauded for the title.
Thank you so much.
It's an amazing show,
and we were off-Broadway at New York Theatre Workshop,
and we're moving to Broadway this fall.
We can't wait. [ Cheers and applause ]
-So I feel like I knew that it was this famous flop,
and I did not know how it was -- And excuse my ignorance.
Within the community of people who like musicals,
was it always this sense of, "This deserves another shot,
this is way better than it got credit for"?
-I think it felt like an incredible score.
Stephen Sondheim did the music and lyrics.
And it was just one of those shows that never quite worked
or people thought it never quite worked.
Our director, Maria Friedman, who is based in London
and did this ten years ago in London,
directed a production of it.
She really believed in the piece,
and we're doing it as written, the book and the lyrics,
and it went really well off-Broadway,
so we're excited to bring it to Broadway.
-And how long have you been off-Broadway yourself?
Like, what was the last time --
Has it been, like, longer than you've been here?
Six years, seven years? -Oh, my God, yeah.
I did "Little Shop of Horrors" in 2019.
This is the first show I've done
since the theater was closed for the pandemic.
I could not stop crying
throughout rehearsal, throughout the --
It was me in the clip from the Night movie.
I was just always like --
About to sing, crying.
It was really emotional and felt so amazing to be back.
And even to see "Wicked," just, like --
It's still not lost on me from being, like, with your --
with you on my iPhone at night, drinking alcohol
and eating protein bars to, like, being on Broadway,
seeing theater, being with a live audience here.
-Yeah. -It's just like --
I'll never forget how much I missed it, yeah.
-It's very exciting to be in front of a live audience.
It's very exciting to be in a live audience.
-Totally. -Like, sitting and watching
things again, it is such a --
And especially being in the city
where I feel like that community, you know --
There's so many different places to go out and see that.
-And it's the best.
Like, New York is the capital of theater,
and the best people do their best work here.
And, yeah, I missed being in the audience just as much,
if not more than I missed being onstage.
-And so this is -- So, when do you go back
into rehearsals for "Merrily" for Broadway?
Like, how much time off do you have?
-Yeah, we have like six or seven months off.
-Okay. And are you just champing
at the bit to get back at it?
-I am. -Yeah.
-When the show would be over off-Broadway --
Daniel Radcliffe is in the show, as well.
He's incredible. And Lindsay Mendez.
[ Audience member whistles ] Yeah. Yeah, Dan. Alright.
And Dan and I had shared a dressing room
off-Broadway with Reg Rogers,
and I would take off my pants, the costume pants.
And I would be like, "I just want to put these back on
and get back out there."
And it was genuine. I'm dying to get back to it.
-I am dying to see it.
It's so exciting, and it's such a great cast.
And, again, it's, you know, a musical.
Like I said, I've only heard about it,
and I'm so excited to finally see it.
-You'll let us know if it works.
-I will. I'm going to talk to your dad
and I'm going to say, "How do you...?"
What are some of the words that he responds to best?
Thank you so much for being here.
It's always such a pleasure. -Thank you, Seth. Thank you.
-You guys, that's Jonathan Groff.
"Knock at the Cabin" in theaters this Friday, February 3rd.
We'll be right back with more "Late Night."